je vais avoir besoin de chacun de vos
témoignages plus tôt je commencerai mon
enquête plus tôt c'est une enquête
un véritable cluedo fin 19ème siècle un
manoir anglais un meurtre et amis lors
d'une soirée de fiançailles fortement
pas de comédie c'est un trailer sais
c'est dur on est tous et des fans de
romans noirs anglais et c'est comme ça
qu'on a voulu à fait interpréter cette
pièce de théâtre c'est une vraie enquête
tout à fait et c'est une très belle
histoire d'amour surtout à c'est-à-dire
il ya à la fois une on peut parler on
peut dire un amour en quelques sortes
incestueux l'aria elle parle des
personnages ne parlent pas des
évidemment c'est effectivement il ya une
histoire d'amour et il faut évidemment
trouver qui est le meurtrier alors on va
pas vous le dévoiler parce que sinon
vous viendrez pas le voir molière de la
comédie 2016 les faux british multiplie
les dates et les applaudissements avec
des comédiens professionnels qui jouent
les amateurs et qui ne s'arrête jamais
j'ai répété le texte devant ma femme si
je les jeux les répéter avec ma femme
d'ailleurs n'est pas tout à fait
d'accord sur l'identité de l'auteur
c'est un peu tendu entre nous c'est un
étang on pense que l'auteur c'est conan
doyle
voilà qui voulaient se débarrasser du
fameux personnage de sherlock holmes
en faisant ce spectacle très important
sur sur sur un meurtre de nouveau dans
un manoir manoir à leur charme
si vous avez raté leur passage à plaisir
de séance de rattrapage le 23 février au
théâtre gérard philipe de saint cyr et
le 19 avril au prisme à elancourt